[Music]
today's talk is going to be about the
intersection of causality and machine
learning and this is arguably a very new
area of research
so in this talk what i'm going to do is
first give a little bit of background on
the core
topics of causality and then i'm going
to try to elucidate this gap between
modern machine learning and modern
fidelity and then we're going to really
explore how these two fields can help
one another okay so i'm going to focus
on two aspects of this i'm going to
broadly call this how ml can help
causality and how the field of causality
can help the field of machine learning
okay so let's dive into this first part
of the talk on what even is causality
and uh
to to do this i thought i'd begin with a
bit of a thought experiment um and so
to be a bit more interactive feel free
to use the q a function to give me the
answer okay um so let's start with a
thought experiment
so suppose i told you that i did a study
and i found a correlation between
writing really long comments on reddit
and getting a lot of upgrades
so just using the q a i want to
have the audience tell me
based on this
finding
would you feel comfortable
uh changing the way you write and start
to write really long reddit comments
okay having a little bit of a hard time
opening up the the q a box but
i'm going to assume that a lot of people
said maybe not
okay and so
what is the intuition that you had um i
bet that you had the intuition that you
know i mentioned that i found this
correlation
and the question that i asked was about
an intervention was about a change was
about taking an action
and fundamentally
these feel like different questions
right um causality is the thing that
underpins
questions that are about intervention
about taking action
upon the world so for example i asked a
very
um
you know question that had to do with
online interactions but there are some
really pressing questions that we want
to answer as a society uh these
questions might be
all the way about what interventions
should we take to address climate change
and reduce emissions
to
you know how should dialogue agents
respond to humans in order to have a
successful exchange uh and then maybe
persist
questions about precision medicine where
doctors might wonder whether they should
prescribe the new antidepressant or the
new medication to treat various types of
disease for different patients
so
what is underpinning all these kinds of
questions that involve taking action
upon the world
fundamentally these are causal questions
and causality is about intervention
so that's just a high-level overview so
let's make this more a little bit more
technical and a bit more formal so let's
take as an example this question
of a clinician asking should i prescribe
the new anti-department
okay so this is a question like i said
about intervening upon the world okay
prescribing and giving the new
antidepressant to their patients
and fundamentally uh
they would take this action
if this intervention had a good outcome
in some sense okay so we need a language
to formalize what is a good intervention
and that's where we're gonna get to in
the next few slides
so
to get there to build this up let me
introduce a little bit of notation so
here's a model of this clinical setting
okay so in this toy model we have
a bunch of complex factors that i'm
calling z
and these complex factors are going to
affect uh whether patients take the new
medication or not okay so that taking a
medication or not is a variable that we
call treatment and here it's being
encoded as a binary variable it's just
people can either take the treatment or
not
okay and we have an outcome of interest
so in this antidepressant example uh the
depression status might be our outcome
of interest that we call y
so here's a model of the world where
these factors affect who choose to take
treatment and the factors also affect
whether uh somebody sees a good recovery
or not
now let's go back to our question about
intervention
okay should i prescribe the new
antidepressant
when i'm asking a causal question i'm
imagining a world in which i intervene
and set the treatment variable to some
value one or zero okay so
um
to make this a little bit more formal we
can introduce some notation um
this interventional question can be
formalized with a special type of
distribution okay this distribution is
going to be indexed by or referenced by
this do t equals one operation but it's
not that complicated it's all it's
saying is that uh i'm asking about a
special type of distribution where i've
intervened okay so i've severed
uh all of the factors that affect
the treatment variable i've intervened
and set t to one and now i'm asking
about the distribution
of my outcomes y
okay so
this is nothing special this is just a
special type of this is just a different
distribution from which i would like to
sample when i'm asking about
interventional questions which underpin
causality
so now i said okay we need a way to talk
about good interventions versus bad
right uh and so there's a lot of ways to
formalize causal questions and and
perhaps the most um
popular one or the most common one is
the average treatment effect
okay in this average treatment effect
we're asking about the average outcome
when i intervene and set the treatment
variable to one
versus when i intervene and set the
treatment variable to zero okay so
putting in this in the context of our
example this um
represents the idea that
you know a antidepressant is a good one
when
intervening and giving people this
antidepressant yields a positive strong
positive change in their outcome okay on
average so this is one type of causal
question
and so far we've talked about causal
questions but we haven't said
how do we actually
answer them how do we get you know data
that looks like it's coming from this
special interventional distribution
and so now that's where i'm going to go
to next and um
some of you may have heard of randomized
control trials
so
like i said in these special
interventional distributions
we were just kind of remind ourselves we
were severing all of the ties between
the factor z
and the treatment variable t okay
and one way to kind of mimic that same
uh structure is by randomly assigning
people treatment okay so we now forcibly
take away the links between the factors
z that affect who chooses to take
treatment or not and instead we have
randomly assigned treatment so this
isn't you know literally the
interventional distribution but it
behaves as though it's the same it's the
same thing and so in this kind of
randomized control trial distribution we
can simply rewrite uh the average
treatment effect by
contrasting the average among the
average outcome among the treated
population and the average outcome among
the control population okay
so we can just look at this difference
and then we have our average treatment
effect which otherwise was written in
terms of interventions which we can't
actually do for every single person
right
okay so that's kind of a nice setting
but what happens when we just have what
i call observational data okay so here
this is just you know nature is going to
hand to you data where these factors d
affect who chooses to take treatment and
what happens to them
so now let's kind of
uh you know take a toy example of this
kind of data so maybe we have a bunch of
records that show us you know who took
the antidepressant and what their
outcome was
okay
um and let's say that the antidepressant
actually has a strong positive causal
effect
uh and we we do the same thing we just
take the difference between the uh
treated group and the untreated group in
terms of their outcome
and we see that you know it yields zero
okay so what happened we we weren't able
to recover the causal effect um
as we were able to before
um
so what happened
so if i kind of expand out this data set
a little bit more what i see is that
these two groups may not actually be
very comparable right the treated group
and the control group those that didn't
receive the treatment might actually
have varied uh in the in the severity of
their their conditions right so here
what we have is that
um
these
factors that affect both who chooses to
take treatment and outcomes they induce
a correlation between the treatment and
outcomes that's not causal
okay and these variables are
are called confounders in the common in
the parlance of causal inference
so these variables they like i said they
create an association between the
treatment variable and the outcome
that is not due to the causal path and
because of this
when we simply look at the
you know the difference in outcomes
between the treated and untreated we're
going to get a biased understanding of
the causal effect
so how do we combat this
um
there is a lot of work on on causal
inference and one idea one technique is
called causal adjustment and i'm just
going to state it informally here and
not mathematically
um
the idea is that we group
by different uh values of the confounder
variables and within each group we can
calculate the difference in outcomes
between the treated and untreated
and then average that difference across
all of the confounder groups okay so the
idea is that you know whatever effect is
left
after we have accounted for the
confounder is going to be the causal
effect okay and of course this is not a
magic bullet this idea of doing
adjustment uh this comes with a very
strong assumption that all of our
confounders are observed okay and of
course um here is a toy situation where
we just have one confounder and it's
binary
but in practice we may have you know
thousands of confounding variables and
they may have lots of different groups
lots of different um kind of discrete
categories or they can be continued
so what we've seen is we've started to
kind of just see informally
that these fundamental steps of causal
inference so now i'll just kind of make
it all more formal and say that when we
do causal inference we typically do it
in three steps okay first we define the
causal quantity of interest okay so i
gave the average treatment effect or the
ate as one example these kinds of
quantities are called estimates
okay so we first define the causal
estimate
then we make assumptions with which we
can rewrite the causal estimate which is
written in terms of these interventional
distributions and we rewrite it in terms
of things we can observe so we saw two
examples of that one when we assumed
that we can randomly assign treatment
and one case where we could observe all
of the confounders and do the causal
adjustment technique
so then of course um we still need to
take
data and and um
learning algorithms to estimate those
quantities uh and so that's the last
phase of puzzle inference in this talk
i'm not going to dwell on the last
piece of estimation i'm going to focus
more on the first two components
but
um so these are the steps of causal
inference and
we we just saw two examples of
assumptions
um let me just
go ahead and open the q a box
and i'll i'll do my best to
keep an eye out on the questions okay
and
i will answer them as in as an event so
let me just do the first one
so
in the toy example why is severity not
considered
a causal effect on the outcome life
um okay so let me go ahead and clarify
that question quickly
so
in this context i want to really
emphasize that
when we write the s demand we specify
what causal effect we care about okay so
indeed z here severity has an effect on
the outcome but that's not the that's
not the causal effect we care about okay
so in this context the clinician wants
to know whether the treatment variable
has a causal effect on why okay and they
want to
kind of account for or um ignore all of
the other factors that could affect y
and they want to isolate the causal
effect of just t on y
okay
okay so like i said um we only saw two
types of assumptions we saw rct
and we saw um
causal adjustment
but we did not see
there are so many other examples that i
um i will kind of just mention here uh
there's a lot of other types of
essentials that have been developed in
the literature um
you can read about instrumental
variables synthetic controls difference
in differences and regression
discontinuity
and
of course there are a lot of other
estimates i mentioned the average
treatment effect uh but there's a lot of
interesting ones like for example we can
try to learn the the causal structure
right so we can try to learn all of the
causal arrows all the causal
relationships between a bunch of
variables so for example maybe um we
want to understand how genes in a big
network cause one another cause and
effect one another
uh i wanna also just emphasize that
again these all of these causal f
demands are
hard questions to answer from
observational data alone so in the case
of causal structure discovery from the
observed correlation we may be able to
orient some of the causal edges but not
all okay so there's the kind of
fundamental difficulty when it comes to
answering causal questions
from non-interventional data
another type of estimate uh is when we
want to do mediation analysis so here we
want to understand kind of which
variables that are live along the
pathway from treatment to outcome
actually carry a lot of the the
treatment effect so in this case maybe
there are lots of different variables
that explain why an antidepressant is
has a causal effect on the outcome and
we want to understand which of these
pathways carries most of the effects
one last example that i'll give here but
of course there are several others in
the literature
is called heterogeneous treatment
effects so here we want to decompose the
average treatment effect uh along
different subgroups of um covariates so
here as an example
we care about let's say age and we want
to understand how different age groups
affect
or experience different kinds of
treatment effects
okay so
there are a lot of different causal
assumptions and there are a lot of
different causal f demands
and um this field of causal inference
has already made a lot of progress along
all of these dimensions
and so you can read about um causality
in a lot of you know really excellent
textbook
um
and
but now what i'd like to focus on is
okay so causality as a field has been
kind of developing and evolving over the
years uh it's a long-standing area of
interest so what is the difference
between causality and machine learning
okay so where where are we now
so to kind of talk about this a little
bit i'd like to start by saying you know
what machine learning them
okay so machine learning is very good
modern machine learning techniques as
you've seen probably in the course of
this
summer school and all the talks
machine learning methods are very good
at learning patterns and learning
associations
so let's kind of go back to a online
forum example like i started in the
thought experiment uh and suppose that
maybe in an online forum
the your um being perceived as a female
has a large effect on the number of
uploads you get
so let's say it has a causal effect
now
if we were to fit a classifier or train
a classifier to predict responses
instead
from a lot of text data and some
variable that perhaps codes for the
perceived gender
what we might see is uh that if i look
at the correlations right the um
importance of different features for the
prediction task
the correlations don't actually
correspond to causal effects
right for example the true causal factor
here might actually have a you know much
smaller correlation than a factor
like uh the topic of the subreddit okay
so
this is very much in line with the adage
that you might have heard that
correlation is not causation
right the
things that are predictive are not the
same factors that you want to intervene
upon to get a certain effect
on the outcome
in contrast you know the field of
causality has focused very much on
uh
measured variables
okay so for example
in
the clinical setting that i talked about
right we presupposed that we had nice
and clean measurements of you know who
took the treatment and who didn't
we had nice clean measurements of the
outcome
and we had nice and clean measurements
of all the confounding factors as well
and in a lot of the settings in which
causal imprints was traditionally
studied
even if a factor like let's say health
status can't directly be measured a
clinician might still know that okay the
combination of you know bmi cholesterol
et cetera et cetera uh will capture this
factor
so
what this does though is um
you know
puts us
in a slightly more constrained space
where we
don't think of using kind of
high dimensional noisy data
so
um
for example
in the kinds of settings that we work
with now
instead of having nice measured
confounding factors we might have
instead clinicians physicians notes
electronic medical records that
encode people's health status and so
forth but in a noisy way
okay so these factors are there but
they're buried in high dimensional data
um
and i'm going to focus on text uh but of
course this this is applicable to images
um experimental data lots of different
kinds of high dimensional data are an
opportunity here
and so continuing this example um we may
not actually know in a lot of contexts
whether
patients took the treatment or not maybe
instead we have some text data that
noisely indicates you know who took what
type of medication
and moreover maybe
language something high dimensional like
uh counseling conversations are the
treatments of interest okay so maybe we
want to ask causal questions not about
whether or not somebody took an
antidepressant but we want to ask causal
questions about um
you know effective counseling
conversational strategy
okay and then finally again we may never
get to measure
uh people's
recovery from um the the treatment
we may instead have open-ended survey
responses like patient self-evaluation
that again encodes the variables of
interest but in high-dimensional noisy
data
okay so let me pause once again quickly
to look at uh some questions
okay and then
there's a question about rl but i think
i'm going to save that until the end for
now
and um i'll i'll answer the second
question does causality have to be
interpretable
um
and
or do we have to can latent variables be
causal variables okay so that's a great
question uh and actually in the next
part of this in the later part of this
talk i'll get there uh so i'll save that
as well
okay so
where i left off is this idea that
um traditionally causality was all about
using um
measured variables nice clean
measurements and high dimensional data
presents an opportunity
now to make use of this opportunity
right we need techniques to extract
those variables from for example text
data
and
you know modern machine learning is
impressive so we have these variables um
or we have these techniques um arguably
large language models extract a lot of
important information from high
dimensional text
but
what
what we think is that um modern these
the information that these methods
extract we don't know if these are sort
of causal variables
right um kind of in line with the
question that was asked um
they extract information but it's not
clear a priority that information
corresponds to the same exact variables
that live in the causal graph that we
draw
so
this idea
that causality and ml have a lot to
offer each other right so with
modern machine learning techniques we
could potentially make
use of
all different kinds of rich high
dimensional data such as text and images
to answer new kinds of causal questions
but causal models on the other hand
might be able to
provide useful
modeling
inductive biases and modeling choices to
learn
better
representations or better predictions
better better predictors
so that is where i'm going to go with
the rest of this talk okay and i'm going
to divide this area into two spaces like
i said first i'm going to talk about how
machine learning techniques can help the
field of fidelity to answer more causal
questions and then we'll talk a little
bit about how causality can help machine
learning
and to do this i'm just going to give
like a vignette essentially uh about
recent work where we use text data to
measure confounders
and to do this i'm going to give a
motivating example um
so we have reddit comments where
the posters have self-labeled their
gender and we also have upvotes to
signal the popularity of the comet and
we might be interested um as you know
cert potential social scientists we
might be interested in the effect that
perceived gender has on common
popularity
and so then um as we were doing before
where we drew causal models of the
clinical setting we might posit a causal
model of the world here
so here we might say that um a reader
comes along when they read a comment and
they choose to give the uppers both both
based on the text and the gender
label that the writer of the comment has
given
okay so these are the two different
variables that affect the upwards
moreover
true but hidden characteristics of the
writer of the comment affect both the
label that they give and the text that
they write
so
for example uh maybe
we will see that
um
people that label themselves as m
have a propensity to talk about certain
topics more often
and maybe these same topics are just
also happen to be popular okay so maybe
certain topics also receive a lot more
uploads on average
okay
so
these
factors like topic and style that affect
both the label that somebody um
that are correlated rather with both
um the label that somebody gives
themselves and the text that they write
these are our confounding variables in
this
causal effect effective interest
and
the key assumption here is that these
confounding variables okay these latent
factors um
that
encode topic and style
they are encoded in the text right so
they the text is a function of these
factors
uh but we don't get to directly um
observe the compounding information
instead we have the text
which is high dimensional
we would like to use those adjustment
methods that i talked about that come
with some assumptions
but
we need an appropriate representation of
the text data
so like i said um
the text is a
function of the confounding variables
here and some other stuff so what we'd
like is to throw away all the other
stuff and capture
only the parts of the text that contain
the confounding information
okay and so
this is
akin to dimensionality reduction right
and so we
want to reduce the text the document
to an embedding that captures its
meaning
but um
and there are many techniques for doing
this but we want to ensure that these
embeddings contain all the confounding
information
okay so a priori some off-the-shelf
technique that embeds text might throw
away
the parts of the text that capture
confounding okay so those techniques
have no reason to to
keep the causal information uh and so a
priority might run into this problem
that they throw away the wrong parts of
the
text information
okay so what are we gonna do um
we can exploit the structure of the
causal model
to
understand
what kinds of patterns
are left by the important confounding
information
so what we see here is that
confounding information
leaves a special signature it is the
stuff that predicts both the treatment
and the outcome
okay so it's the the parts of text that
are you know predictive of the treatment
of the outcome and we can use that
learning signal
to learn embeddings that
predict the treatment and outcome well
and we can use that strategy
to learn embeddings that
capture kind of causally sufficient
information
okay so i'm going to give an example of
how you would develop such a embeddings
using bert um so you know bert is able
to take a sequence of tokens and produce
um
an embedding for the entire sentence or
the entire document
um
and we're going to ask this embedding to
be good at two different kinds of
attacks so first we're going to train
the embeddings to be good at predicting
the outcome
okay for both the
group of documents that were treated and
the group of documents that didn't
receive treatment
and we can do this for example by
minimizing the squared error to the true
outcome label
then we're also going to train another
classifier to take the embedding and
predict the treatment uh variable well
and we can do this for example by
minimizing um cross-entropy loss against
the true treatment labels
okay so we do this and um we can also
jointly train with the original
embedding objective that makes the
embeddings be good at capturing semantic
information
so when we when we take this together
what happens if we train a model using
documents
the treatment label which captures the
self-label gender of the writer and the
outcome um which captures reddit upvotes
we train this classifier uh and and all
of the embedding and what we get is for
each document
or for each sentence we get
a
embedding and we get three different
predictions
okay so we trained classifiers remember
and we get we can get three different
predictions
and i said a little i said that i would
mostly skip the idea about estimation uh
but i'm just going to quickly say here
that the key is that those three
predictions that this model is able to
give us are all we need to be able to
estimate the causal effect okay so um
we're not going to dwell on the math
here it's not super important
the key thing to realize is
we can simply write down estimators of
causal effects using those
the three exact predictions that that
causal burp model gave us
so um
i'm just going to also flag an important
problem here which is that you know this
is all well and good but
we don't really know how to evaluate um
methods that estimate causal effect
and this is because
unlike machine learning the goal is not
to predict the label for
every sample the goal is to to um
correctly estimate a causal effect and
in the absence of brown truth known
causal effects it's hard to evaluate
these methods
um
one technique that we've developed in
our work is to simulate outcomes only
using real data like real treatment
labels
text and other covariates
and
thereby control
uh the causal effect we can simulate or
create
um a causal effect
but i want to just flag that this idea
about developing new evaluations for
causal inference and causal effect
estimation this is a great open area of
research
and then it turns out that this idea of
causally sufficient text embedding
is a kind of general purpose tool
so there's another kind of problem here
in the same context where instead of
treatment variables
like
labeled gender
we might ask about treatments that are
that are aspects of the text so for
example i might ask the question how
does um perceived enthusiasm or
perceived politeness affect the number
of upvotes so now the treatment is both
latent
and it is an it's a hidden property of
the text itself
and i'm not gonna go into
um
this other paper but we have a paper
that uh shows how
these causal sufficient embedding again
are a crucial artificial ingredient in
yielding valid causal inference when
treatments are latent aspects of tests
and
i'm going to give a couple more quick
examples of how machine learning has
helped causality
so uh
in the context of social networks um
there's been
you know this is another sort of success
story
uh where
um
we can use network embeddings to capture
confounding information using
probabilistic models or um
uh neural neural embeddings of
social networks
so for example in a recent paper we
estimated the causal effect that people
have on their peers and we were able to
use probabilistic models
of networks to capture the confounding
information in this problem
okay similarly there's been work that
has used networks assigned information
for treatment effect estimation and they
use network embeddings to
extract confounders
in a way that's very similar to the um
causally sufficient text embeddings that
i just talked about
another nice um use case where machine
learning has helped causality is around
causal structure discovery which i
talked about
and so here um
searching over the space of causal
graphs
is
a very hard combinatorial problem
and recently um relaxations that have
yielded differentiable objectives
instead
have led to
efficient optimization using kind of
modern auto differentiation tools and so
that has been
a nice use of machine learning uh and
there's other work that uses ideas from
meta learning to understand the causal
direction between variables
uh and then finally i talked about
heterogeneous that this idea that we
want to understand
how
different groups of people
experience the average treatment effect
and so
in this context machine learning methods
like random forest have been extended to
estimate the subgroup effects
and
work has gone even further to use
machine learning methods to
estimate individual level treatment
effects so understand the treatment
effect not just for a subgroup but for
such a fine-grained subgroup that it you
know starts to get it um how in you know
any one individual
um
experiences the treatment effect
okay so that's sort of a vignette of how
machine learning methods can be used to
make more out of the data that we have
the high dimensional data that we have
and
um help with
estimating treatment effects and
answering more causal questions
so now we're going to talk i'm going to
talk a little bit about how causality
can help machine learning
so
what we're
is that causality is the calculus of
intervention
right so it is a language it's a
mathematical language that helps us
quantify the effects that interventions
have on the world
so how does this connect to machine
learning
so
as one example
right we often
are operating under changing
distributions in machine learning
so for example um maybe we're training a
classifier to recognize
animals and images
and in our training data
we have cows that often appear in grassy
background
and maybe in our test distribution
something has changed and instead now
we're going to get photos of cows that
appear uh on beaches instead
okay so um
here
this is not about interventions that we
might make around the world this is
about unknown interventions
uh that the world kind of makes but that
change the distributions of data that we
get to see
and so this is where we can start to use
the tools of causality to formalize and
analyze this problem
so
let me stress here that the goal is now
different we're not trying to
estimate an average treatment effect
now we might be trying to learn a
predictor from a bunch of features x
where
the training distribution of these
features
um
might be very different than the
distribution of these features in our
test data
and this difference in distribution
could be due to unknown interventions
that the world has taken to change
change our features
and here
like i said the goal may not be to um
estimate effects but to understand you
know what is the risk of this predictor
under
changing distributions of features
okay so how can we bring in the language
of causality
we might start by talking about a model
of the world here again okay so um here
we might see that
some of some variables x1 x2 x3 in this
case
are causal parents of some label of
interest y
okay and there's now
this confounding variable u
that has
an effect on all of the features
and we might have some features that are
like x4 here that are not a causal
parent of y
but are are correlated with y
okay this is sort of like in the example
i gave uh around perceived gender and
text and
outcomes
um we have here a feature that's
correlated with y but doesn't actually
cause y
okay so why does this matter right um
it matters because
when an intervention is taken upon the
system
and the distribution of the features
changes
the mass of causality tells us that the
causal relationships between
the causal parents of why
and why
those causal relationships don't change
but the spurious relationships may
change
okay so this
is a powerful lever for us when we build
classifiers because
we if we want a classifier whose risk
um stays the same
under arbitrary interventions to the
train and test data or to the training
data
then we would like a classifier we could
try to exploit this invariant
and
learn a classifier
that uses the causal parents of why
okay rather than the um the spurious
features
whose spurious relationships with why
can change across different
interventions
okay but it's not so simple to learn
causal relationships that's kind of been
the theme of this talk that from
observational data alone it's not so
simple to learn um causal relationships
so what what can we do here
um so
recent work has tried to exploit
many many many interventions okay so
these are often called environments upon
which
uh in which
in each environment some intervention
has been taken
and what we can do is try to use these
changing environments
to
learn
the relationships between x and y that
are invariant and therefore causal
and separate out those that are spurious
and therefore changing across
environments okay and so recent work has
introduced a differentiable objective
for this problem
that can exploit multiple interventional
environments
so this is one way in which
the language of causality can help us
formalize um
the the problem of
invariant
risk and classifiers that have some
notion of stability across changing
distribution
okay and so we talked about
representation learning and um whether
these
latent variables could be causal
variables and that's where i'm gonna get
to now
so um
another we can kind of go past
supervised learning right and um
we can talk about unsupervised learning
where maybe some latent variables z1
through z4 here
um
create the data
uh let me just
check the q a really quickly
okay so
now we're talking about representation
learning where the
latent variables create some high
dimensional data so here you know
there's four factors just as a toy
example that create a high dimensional
image of a cow
so what does it mean
to ask for
causal variables
so
we might want for example these latent
variables z1 through z4
to
capture some causal structure we might
want to we might want them to capture
information
such that for example if we intervened
on one of the variables then maybe the
cow would stay the same but the
background alone would change so in this
case maybe z3 captures the background
okay so
we might
use this kind of interventional quant
criteria as a way to define what we mean
by causal variable in in
representation learning
um
but
this is
first off this is this is kind of a
challenge for multiple reasons
right so now we would like to learn
variable latent variables that have some
sort of causal relationships with one
another
um and
the challenge really gets compounded
here because we already said that
inferring causal structure from
observations alone is impossible
um
and that
inferring the true late variables from
observations
is also generically um
impossible without further assumption
okay so from observations alone uh it is
hard to recover exactly z1 z2 z3 and z4
we might instead learn arbitrary um
functions
that entangle all of these variables
okay so this idea that okay now can we
learn uh causal representations from
observational data
or how you know can we learn causal
representations from data
um
this is
arguably a very very new problem and
it's been receiving a lot of attention
and there's been a lot of work
um
and the progress so far has relied on
different kinds of assumptions and data
so for example
there's been work that has used
temporal observations
where uh
the the you know as time goes there are
very sparse changes in the observational
data
uh there's our work that has
used sparsity in a different way that
has exploited sparse mappings from the
latent variables to the the the features
that we observe
uh and there's work that uses um
interventions upon the latent
as well as multiple views of the data
such as using
images that have been rotated
or images that have been transformed in
other ways
so
um this
field of causal representation learning
um
very much kind of connects to this idea
that i talked about earlier that uh we
want to learn representations
right variables uh that capture low
dimensional features of our data
but that have certain
special structures right they might have
certain causal properties like when we
intervene upon them the changes kind of
are meaningful um or they
capture certain causal relationships
with other
latent variables or other parts of the
data
and
the work that i talked about with
causally sufficient text embeddings you
can think of it as a as a small step in
this direction there we used a special
type of signature in the data to learn
those kinds of variables
uh and then
we could go much much bigger um and try
to learn
you know
a whole bunch of latent variables that
are able to encode these kinds of
special structures and causal property
but this is again like i said this is a
new field of research and there's still
a lot of work to be done here
so causal models in machine learning
have showed up in other places so for
example causal models of decision making
processes have been useful
for quantifying
algorithmic bias and unfairness
um causal models of beta have also been
useful for identifying why spurious
correlations show up in the first place
and
uh ha you know more ways of being able
to
avoid using spurious features and
predictions
um
so these are just some vignettes
okay so
i'm now going to
uh you know leave some time for q a as
well as
uh just end this talk by summarizing
lots and lots of areas of new research
okay so
for one
the
intersection that i talked about
where we can use machine learning
techniques to exploit lots more types of
data
this could have an impact in a lot of
application areas all the way from
precision medicine and molecule design
to
algorithmic decision making fairness and
social science
uh moreover i talked a lot about text
data in this talk
but there's a lot of opportunities to
combine multiple modalities of data like
text and images to do both better
representation learning as well as
better treatment effect estimation
and then finally
i've been emphasizing throughout this
talk that this idea of causal
representation learning um is kind of
new
research and it's a big field all unto
itself
and there's a lot of opportunities to
think about how to combine
observational data as well as active
learning to kind of gather
interventional data in the most
effective manner possible
and of course know there are questions
about rl and so on and uh i can
we can go ahead and talk about that in
the the q a part of the stuff
let me go ahead and open up the q a now
and start looking at some of these
questions so
the most recent question
was about selecting intervention
uh so assuming we have a graph data set
um
and we have a large number of possible
interventions how do we decide which
ones to take
uh can we use some properties of the
graph observational data to assign a
score to each intervention and select
them according to the score okay great
um so thanks for the question uh amir um
so
i think it's worth kind of highlighting
um
a couple of different places in which
interventions show up
so
in the first part of the talk where
we're talking about treatment effect
estimation
there a researcher or a scientist will
specify specifically what intervention
they're interested in so we might be
asking about intervening on
um
drug treatments that patients are given
we might ask about intervening on the
gender labels that we see on social
media platforms like reddit
in that context um
the nature of the intervention is a bit
cleaner
now when we're talking about
work on causal representation learning
or causal discovery where we want to
do interventions perhaps actively in
order to
uh learn causal graphs or causal
structures
you're absolutely right that it is hard
to design or hard to think about what
intervention to ask for next okay so um
for this i'm just going to point to
there's a lot of work uh on
or there's kind of emerging work rather
on the area of active learning of
intervention
okay and so this is kind of an i i would
argue this is a um very
new and um
fruitful line of research uh but the
place to look at about how to
score which intervention is a good one
based on the information gain that it
gives you uh you can you can read about
it by reading about active learning of
intervention
uh and then i want to focus on one more
question that was asked about rl
um
and so let me just paraphrase the
question here that it's supervised
machine learning and unsupervised
learning um arguably also is all about
association
but can we consider rl as another
framework to study cause and effect and
um
so that's a great question and in fact
um
there's a lot of work that is
currently actively exploring the
intersection or the the commonalities
between rl and
um
interventional notions of causality like
i talked about in this talk
um
and it
it does seem like there's a lot of
overlap between the mathematical tools
of rl and those of causality
um so i think that again is a very
active area of research right now and
one that's definitely worth exploring
thank you so much for this great talk
[Music]
you